il est 16 heures 14 bientôt 16h15
l'heure à laquelle la dubai d'hommes
doit arriver à genève en suisse à la
veille de son sommet avec vladimir
poutine le président et il arrivait
justement on va poser la question à
notre envoyé spécial olivier de 40 flec
olivier je le disais 16h15 l'heure à
laquelle étaient censés arriver jo
d'haydn à genève en suisse
est ce que joe biden est arrivé alors
écoutez tiers n'ont pas encore en tout
cas l'information ne nous est pas
parvenu pour les mais pour le moment
tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'on vient d'entendre un cortège vous
entendez peut-être d'ailleurs en ce
moment même les sirènes à dernière nous
beaucoup de véhicules de police qui sont
en train de se diriger en direction a
précisément de l'aéroport de genève et
puis également un hélicoptère qui
survole le lac alors pour parler
justement de cette arrivée de joe bayane
de l'état d'esprit du président
américain
je suis avec le docteur gabriel galice
et le président de l'institut
international de recherche pour la paix
à genève à genève gabriel gay galice
bonjour merci d'être avec nous cet
après-midi pour décrypter les enjeux de
cette visite est particulièrement
peut-être un mot sur l'état d'esprit du
président américain on le sait est un
qui revient de réunions avec les
représentants du g7 et de l'otan oui
visiblement le président byden a voulu
resserrer son camp autour de lui avant
de avant de rencontrer le président
russe il a souhaité faire l'unité de son
propre camp et répété qu'il était le
leader
alors je pense que c'est de bonne guerre
si on ose dire mais maintenant il faut
entrer dans la phase la plus difficile
c'est à dire rencontré celui qui est
désigné comme l'adversaire et la menace
est là on est dans un autre registre
parce que les russes et les chinois ont
été désignés notamment par le manifeste
autant 2030 comme la menace des années à
venir
donc il faudra parler de ces questions
là est ce que c'est une menace est ce
qu'on peut calmer le jeu est ce qu'on
peut aborder les dossiers difficiles
comme le craignent
irie la méditerranée y compris au nord
stream 2 qui s'est un peu apaisée mais
ça va revenir c'est pas tout à fait fini
donc il ya vraiment matière à discuter
beaucoup de tension effectivement à sur
de nombreux dossiers
vous venez de les évoquer pour autant
c'est important cette rencontre
aujourd'hui le monde aura les yeux
tournés vers genève
mais il est toujours important de se
parler il ya eu des insultes à distance
qui sont de mauvaise augure
et maintenant il faut se rencontrer avec
des déclarations officielles puis aussi
des tête-à-tête privé il ya toujours des
rencontres privées en dehors des
journalistes et en dehors de beaucoup de
personnes
et c'est parfois là où on peut débloquer
des dossiers donc moi je suis optimiste
parce que sinon ça serait désespérant si
les deux présidents accepté de se
rencontrer c'est qu'ils ont envie de
faire avancer au moins un certain nombre
de dossiers parce que effectivement on
sait qu'il n'ya plus d'ambassadeur dans
les capitales respectives des deux
puissances depuis plusieurs moins depuis
mois d'avril est ce que cela ça pourrait
être par exemple et bien un accord c'est
à dire de nouveau des ambassadeurs dans
les ambassades respectives de ces deux
pays par exemple ça serait déjà une
chose de concrète à mettre sur place
pour faciliter les canaux de
communication et envoyé des signes
positifs mais y en ad'autres
effectivement qui doivent être mis sur
la table alors vous parliez de cette
diplomatie offensive des américains
finalement elle ne va pas d'aujourd'hui
mais moi je suis toujours surpris de
voir beaucoup de commentateurs qui
essaye de faire des grosses différences
entre les présidents et s'imaginer
kantien nouveau président ça va faire
une nouvelle politique
or si vous regardez bien la politique
des états unis depuis plusieurs
décennies
il ya beaucoup de continuité un peu de
changements avec obama on avait un style
différent
il était sympa il était souriant il
était un peu plus avocat et un peu moins
militaire et il faisait plus la guerre à
distance par drones et il faisait plus
de l'espionnage à travers la msa que des
guerres direct mais au fond et une une
idée que les etats-unis ont gardé mais
depuis leur origine c'est la notion de
leadership et tant qu'on n'aura pas une
notion de partnership qui sera mise en
avant sur un pied d'égalité dans un
monde qui est devenue non seulement
multilatérale mais multipolaire parce
qu'il ya la russie mais il ya aussi la
chine mais il ya aussi
lundi le brésil il ya tous les autres
donc on peut pas continuer à faire comme
si l'ouest
alès positionner toujours en phase de
l'asie et des méchants russes et des
maisons chinois ça tient pas la route et
c'est pas crédible
pour autant est ce que il ya des
dossiers sur lequel les deux puissances
et bien elles peuvent se rejoindre je
pense notamment au climat par exemple le
climat est un dossier où ils peuvent se
retrouver
c'est évident il ya d'autres dossiers
sur lesquels ils peuvent arriver à
trouver des compromis lesquels ça va
être difficile mais par exemple sur la
syrie quand même c'est un dossier qui
est refroidi mais mais les braises sont
encore là c'est pas tout à fait un plus
sous les autres sur la libye la question
de la question de la turquie mais qui
est liée aussi aux autres pays
environnants donc beaucoup de choses qui
peuvent être l'objet de rapprochements
peut-être pour conclure cette dernière
question
sergueï lavrov le ministre des affaires
étrangères lui disait pas de percée
diplomatique impact décision historique
il ne faut pas s'attendre à de décision
historique justement selon vous après
cette rencontre
moi je ne lis pas dans le marc de café
et puis en plus je suis moins bien
informés que monsieur lavaud refera ci
lui dit qu'il aura pas de devancer
historique c'est qu'il a des raisons de
le dire moi je suis analyste je suis pas
je suis pas acteur de ce dispositif
je pense que on jugera sur pièce moi je
suis chercheur je juge sur pièce je fais
pas de la magie ni de la prévision de
l'astrologie
merci beaucoup monsieur gabriel galice
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
cet après midi en direct de genève alors
l'avion de joe biden est en train en ce
moment même d'arriver me dit on alors je
me tourne pour voir effectivement on
voit un avion peut-être que la caméra de
jordi demory qui nous accompagnent va
pouvoir nous montrer non c'est un petit
peu loin mais effectivement alors voilà
l'avion présidentiel américain est en
train d'arriver
actuellement à l'aéroport de genève
d'ailleurs je vous le disais l'hôtel
intercontinental dans lequel est bien
joe biden va séjourner et complètement
bouclé un et piétons
ni voiture plus personne ne peut
circuler aux abords de cet hôtel
intercontinental
alors voilà le on voit l'avion
présidentiel qui s'apprête à se poser
d'ici quelques minutes à l'aéroport de
genève alors nous sommes avec toujours
gabriel galice qui est avec nous un de
l'institut international de recherche
pour la paire à genève donc je baille
donne qui arrive en ce moment même après
une tournée européenne
oui effectivement il est allé à londres
pour le g7 il est allé à bruxelles pour
rencontrer à l'otan et il sait que
l'otan est assez divisés d'ailleurs
puisque certains pays sont
particulièrement soucieux d'être sur des
positions des états unis d'autres
souhaitent se démarquer
donc il a voulu marquer ça on sait pas
ce qu'il s'est dit en privé et parfois
l'arbre cache la forêt j'ai entendu que
le président macron avait discuté que le
premier ministre russe des saucisses en
irlande
j'espère qu'ils n'ont pas parlé que de
ça pour savoir s'il y avait d'autres
disent dossier mais on le saura dans les
jours qui viennent j'espère voilà si
vous nous rejoignez en direct sur rt
france depuis genève et bien l'avion
présidentiel américain est en train
d'atterrir en ce moment même à
l'aéroport de genève donc joe biden qui
est le premier des deux présidents à
arriver à genève vous voyez en direct
les images alors c'est la ville à la
grange que vous voyez actuellement
l'antenne c'est là-bas que que les deux
hommes vont se parler demain alors une
rencontre pour le moment dont on ne
connaît pas précisément les modalités
vous voyez en direct ces images en
direct de
l'aéroport de genève le président
américain joe biden qui arrive à
l'instant
après une tournée européenne donc tout
d'abord avec les dirigeants du g7 à une
réunion au royaume uni et puis une
réunion à bruxelles avec les
représentants de l'otan voilà donc à
l'instant
l'avion du président américain le
premier donc des chefs d'état arrivé à
genève
[Musique]
pour un sommet à un sommet qui débutera
demain entre vladimir poutine et joe
biden alors là nous sommes toujours avec
gabriel galice le président de
l'institut international de recherche
pour la paix à genève alors il ya une
autre information à qui nous est parvenu
c'est qu'il n'y aura pas de conférence
de presse commune entre les deux hommes
entre vladimir poutine et joe biden
c'est une volonté américaine comment
est-ce que vous la comprenez je pense
qu'ils veulent garder le monopole de
leur expression de leur côté ces
randonnées un peu dans la même
perspective ils ont pas trop envie de
partager la scène donc chacun
s'exprimera de son côté ce qui enlève un
petit peu du caractère unitaire au moins
dans la symbolique d'une rencontre quand
on se rencontre
il est d usage de parler ensemble même
si on dit pas tout à fait les mêmes
choses
maintenant s'il ne le souhaite pas et
bien je dirais que nous verrons le
résultat
alors si vous nous rejoignez vous êtes
donc en direct sur rt france depuis
genève et vous le voyez sur ces images
l'avion du président américain à joe
biden qui vient tout juste d'arriver à
l'aéroport de genève pour le sommet avec
son homologue russe vladimir poutine
alors le président américain qui va
loger à l'hôtel intercontinental
incertain un lieu qui est excentré de la
position nous sommes excentrés du parc
la grange où les deux hommes se
rencontreront
c'est un hôtel qui a l'habitude
d'accueillir des chefs d'état au moins
300 d'ailleurs ils sont passés depuis
et c est là bas donc joe biden va
séjourner durant son séjour à genève
alors nous sommes toujours avec gabriel
galice de l'institut international
de recherche pour la paix à genève pour
suivre en direct cette arrivée du
président joe biden qu'est ce que vous
retenez vous de cette tournée européenne
du président américain
je retiens qu'il se passe quelque chose
qui a une volonté de 2
regardez un peu ce qui se passe vous
savez qu'à un moment on avait parlé du
basculement vers le pacifique comme
étant sous la période obama un tournant
décisif
en réalité ça s'est pas passé comme ça
exactement il s'est passé beaucoup de
choses en eurasie parce que c'est leur
asie qui est qui et le continent majeur
et l'europe est une partie de l'eurasie
donc c'est vraiment cette pour pour les
géopolitologue et pour les stratèges
américains
il faut absolument essayer de de
consolider leur domination et leur
influence sur ce continent eurasiatique
et la tête de pont basse et l'europe de
l'ouest et donc il ya une vision
consistant à dire c'est l'europe de
l'ouest contre un petit peu ce qui se
passe plus loin et l'ukraine étant
d'ailleurs la charnière c'est pas par
hasard si c'est passé les événements en
ukraine c'est que c'est la marche
frontières comme on le dit en ukrainien
et c'est là où est la charnière entre
les deux parties de l'europe et c'est
donc décisif de devoir est de refaire
des passerelles plutôt que des murs
parce que la tentation c'est de refaire
des murs on a détruit le mur de berlin
mais on est en train d'en faire d'autres
et donc ça ça doit ça doit quand même
être sorti des esprits pour arriver vers
une diplomatie qui reprenne ses droits
et qu'on se parle
traditionnellement en moi je pense qu'il
faudra d'ailleurs aller plus loin il
faudra qu'on passe du bilatéralisme dans
lequel on est maintenant un
multilatéralisme
il va falloir que l'onu arrive à
remettre le 21e siècle et le nouveau un
nouvel agenda pour le 21e siècle sur la
table ça n'a pas été fait au sortir de
la guerre froide ça devrait être fait
maintenant parce qu'il ya eu trop de
choses qui se qui se traitent au coup
par coup
au lieu d'avoir une vision d'ensemble
notamment pour ne pas oublier les
chinois est-ce qu'on peut pas faire
comme si les chinois n'oubliez pas on
peut pas non plus jouer les russes
contre les chinois ou les chinois contre
les russes c'est un peu une tentation du
certain nombre de dirigeants aux états
unis je dis pas de joe biden lui même
mais on sait très bien qu'il ya ceux qui
voient le principal adversaire comme
étant les chinois et l'autre que pour
lesquelles ces les russes bon mais c'est
pas comme ça qu'il faut voir le problème
il faut d'ailleurs ça a poussé sa
poussée russes et chinois à coopérer
dans l'organisation de coopération de
shanghai
qui est une réponse à l'otan et à toutes
les formes d'expression occidental donc
il faut mettre ça à plat et je pense
qu'il faudra aller vers le
multilatéralisme
alors si vous nous rejoignez en direct
sur rt france nous sommes à genève où
l'avion du président américain joe biden
vient d'atterrir
le dr gabriel galice président de
l'institut international de recherche
pour la paix à genève est avec nous un
pour vivre ce moment alors vous le voyez
à la porte du de l'avion du président
américain qui vient de s'ouvrir
il devrait descendre d'ici quelques
secondes maintenant il va être accueilli
par le président de la confédération
suisse
guy parmelin d'ailleurs un qui s'est
réjoui de cette rencontre la suisse je
vous le rappelle qui a le statut de pays
neutre depuis 1815 et qui a une bonne on
vient tradition en matière d'accueil et
de médiation justement docteur gabriel
galice aussi le pourquoi la suisse est
ce que c'est symbolique aussi que cette
rencontre se fasse aujourd'hui à genève
bien sûr la suisse joue ce rôle de
facilitateur et vous savez que quand
deux pays rompent leurs relations
diplomatiques
ils ont parfois des des porte parole via
un pays tiers qui s'interpose et dans le
cas de la rupture des relations
diplomatiques entre l'iran et les
etats-unis la suisse a représenté les
intérêts des états unis à terre idem
pour cuba sous le canton et les rues les
russes et les quand les américains et
les les cubains ont rompu leurs
relations
effectivement la suisse joue son rôle
soit façon officielle soit de façon
officieuse en préparant le terrain pour
des rencontres officielles
donc ça c'est une c'est une tradition et
c'est quelque chose qui fonctionne assez
bien qui avait très bien fonctionné
souvenez vous au moment de la crise
ukrainienne la suisse préside l ouest c
e et elle a joué un rôle très positif
avec monsieur burkhalter qui était le
chef de la diplomatie suisse et qui a
abouti à des solutions concrètes qui
n'ont pas été retenu pour les par tous
les protagonistes on va pas revenir là
dessus mais la suisse avait fait sa part
du travail
après si si les autres ne veulent pas
suivre ils ont qu'elle prépare bien le
terrain
la capacité allant dans la crédibilité
et j'espère que ça va se manifester
cette fois encore et on l'évoquait un
gabriel galice cette diplomatie
offensive de joe biden avant cette
rencontre finalement comment est-ce que
vous la comprenez je pense qu'il est
aussi comme tous les présidents situé
dans un environnement administratif et
politique qui fait autant pression sur
lui que lui fait pression sur eux les la
plupart des équipes sont sont pas partis
avec donald trump qui a quand même des
gens d'influencé qui sont toujours là
les faucons si vous voulez se retrouvent
aussi bien chez les démocrates que chez
les républicains c'est une autre idée
fausse qu'on a parfois eu en dix ans les
faucons qui sont réactionnaires ils sont
républicains et puis les démocrates ils
seront gentils progressiste ben ça c'est
une illusion d'optique vous regardez les
élus démocrates
il y en a qui sont carrés qui se réclame
du socialisme et y en a qu un grand
nombre qui sont d'anciens cadres de la
cia bon je pense pas que du jour au
lendemain il soit devenu jeu devenu
socialiste quoi bon donc c'est pas les
mêmes il ya vraiment deux deux courants
différents et il ya même un intergroupe
il ya même un intergroupe parlementaire
de ce qu'ils sont des durs entre
républicains et c'est le parti qu'on
appelle parfois le complexe militaro
industriel mais c'est devenu beaucoup
plus compliqué que ce que c'était il ya
50 ans donc ils sont ils sont sur cette
position là moi ce qui m'inquiète
j'attends de juger sur pièce j'attends
de voir comment joe biden va abandonner
ou par les embargo contre cuba le
venezuela l'iran voilà ça ce sont des
actes concrets
le reste c'est des petites phrases c'est
c'est pour la galerie et ça amuse et
éventuellement les gens mais c'est pas
c'est pas ça la politique politique
c'est les actes donc voyons sur les
actes qu est-ce qui va être faire dans
le monde pour faire baisser les tensions
iran venezuela syrie cuba
ce sont des dossiers très concret est
actuellement vous avez eu le parlement
européen qui vient de voter des
sanctions sous influence américaine
contre cuba on vient de nouveau de
répéter alors que tu vas ne menacent
plus personne ne veut dire y'a plus de
missiles à cuba c'est fini cette
histoire là cuba envoie des médecins en
amérique latine et en afrique
bon et on fait d embargo sur le matériel
médical c'est complètement anachronique
on est dans un monde qui n'a plus de
raison d'être et je crois qu'il faudra
qu'on sorte de ses illusions là de façon
douce ou de façon moins 12 parce qu'on
ne pourra pas y rester et on voit bien
que que l'iran résiste sp espérer faire
tomber le régime avec de l'embargo c'est
de la naïveté on fait encore plus
corus et l'union de la population contre
les ennemis de l'extérieur c'est connu
comme processus
donc c'est pas une bonne politique je
pense que de ce point de vue là obama
avait fait quelque chose de positif avec
la syrie avec cuba comme d'ailleurs les
européens
à ce moment là il était dans le même
bateau et maintenant les européens
devraient peut-être jouer ce rôle en
disant faute est qu'on revienne à ça ils
ont essayé de le faire à mon avis un peu
timidement alors il ya quelques jours la
lumière poutine et bien a fait part de
sa sympathie à l'endroit de donald trump
haye il a salué le président quelle
différence puisque vous pouvez souligné
avec sa relation avec joe biden était un
électron libre
alors il avait il avait d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs poutine l'a ajoutée dans la
deuxième partie de sa déclaration il a
dix avaient des arrêts des avantages et
des inconvénients
c'est à dire que la saillie changer de
cap très vite alors que bagdad lui il
est dans la continuité c'est quand même
c'est quand même quelqu'un qui a un long
passé il c'est un ancien du vietnam
c'est en ce cas sous thil guerre en irak
est bon il a il a derrière lui un passé
affirmé militarisé ancré dans donkey là
il a une une colonne vertébrale je
dirais alors que alors que trump c'est
un homme d'affaires qui est arrivé un
peu accidentellement dans la politique
c'est pas le cas de ben laden c'est un
homme du sérail
donc bien sûr que ça fait une grosse
différence avantage c'est qu'on peut
parler entre professionnels du point de
vue de poutine inconvénient ce qui a
parfois à trouver à faire bouger une
machine qui est à l'air d'être
particulièrement lourde
et puis on ne sait pas exactement quelle
est la fraction de son entourage qui va
avoir le dernier mot et pour le moment
on entend beaucoup les faucons on voit
pas beaucoup se lever des signes
positifs en faveur d'une détente avec
les uns avec les autres
c'est pour ce que vous appelez la
diplomatie agressive moi je crois que
c'est ça qui peut être inquiétant on
attend une diplomatie coopérative plutôt
qu'une démocratie une diplomatie
agressive parce que diplomatie par
définition ça doit être un peu
coopératif quand même il y a dans cette
diplomatie des six jeunes hippies ne on
peut citer la fere navalni par exemple
ou encore le dossier biélorusse un peu
plus récemment
quel est votre regard il peut y avoir un
échange sur ces dossiers entre les deux
présidents oui peut y avoir un échange
mais je pense que l'ailé les choses sont
asymétriques
navalni là quand même un passé qui est
pas si glorieux
je veux dire c'est quand même c'est
quand même pas le pauvre à 100 jeunes au
risque est quand même extraordinaire
c'est tout le monde s'est retrouvé à
londres et on a fait comme si assange
était pas en bastille et alors que rien
ne prouve qu'il est coupable pour le
moment il ya des accusations qui sont
légères un dossier épais pour faire pour
faire rayonner mais les actions
concrètes ce qu'on lui a surtout
reproché
c'était d'avoir révélé des crimes de
guerre bon voilà votre responsabilité
d'assange
j'exclus pas que là dedans il ya aussi
les discussions sur snowden parce qu'on
en parle plus noden mais c'est quand
même un cas assez assez extraordinaire
cet homme là qui est libertariens à
l'origine veut dire les libertariens
sais pas c'est pas des communistes du
tout donc c'est pas quelqu'un qui serait
allé par nostalgie de l'ancienne union
soviétique se réfugie à moscou donc pour
eux ce nice snowden ça reste un problème
donc je pense que toutes ces choses vont
être mis sur la table comment le par
définition ça sera pas tout public
mais ça fait partie des choses qui
préoccupent les américains et à bon
droit mais seulement de toute façon
maintenant le
les lanceurs d'alert ont pris le relais
et même en les mettant en prison
continue alors alors que nous voyons en
direct le président américain joe biden
sortir à l'instant de son avion air
force one
il a atterri il y a une dizaine de
minutes maintenant à l'aéroport
international de genève
il salue c'est guy parmelin le président
de la confédération suisse qui
l'accueille
on voit les deux hommes ont échangé
quelques mots
l'arrivée de joe biden donc que vous
vivez en direct sur rt france
et pour commenter ces images avec nous
gabriel galice président de l'institut
international de recherche pour la paix
à genève
donc le mal mais je présume qui doit
aussi rencontrer une délégation de
l'état de genève puisqu'ils arrivent ils
arrivent quand même dans une république
et donc les personnalités représentante
le canton doivent être là mais avec le
soleil on voit assez mal donc à et c'est
effectivement les différents échelons
politiques de la confédération de l'état
de la ville qui comme d'habitude
reçoivent le chef d'état donc voilà le
protocole pour joe biden qui salue ses
hôtes de la suisse 1 la suisse
finalement qui est ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui qu'elle renoue avec sa
longue tradition d'accueil et de
médiation elle n'a jamais cessé
alors si pendant là pendant la guerre où
les guerres c'était plus difficile mais
sinon la suisse a toujours essayé de
garder cette caractéristique ne faut pas
oublier que l'ancêtre de l'onu c'est la
société des nations et la société des
nations avait son siège là bas ça
c'était du temps où l'europe dominer le
monde
le siège était à genève depuis il ya eu
quand même un tournant et l'onu s'est
installé dans sa fonction principale
aux etats unis à new york et puis ici il
ya quand même une deuxième une deuxième
aux nues tout notamment se passe ta
conférence de désarmement qui maintient
des choses qui fait un certain travail
donc oui genève a gardé cette cette
fonction là c'est une des villes qu'on
appelle la genève internationale qui
intervient dans le jeu diplomatique et
qui a maintient cette tradition depuis
la sdn en 1919 s'est installé en 1920
après la création a été décidée en 1919
donc c'est vrai que que là on est dans
une dans une terre où la diplomatie joue
toujours son rôle
la suisse comme vous le savez parmi les
caractères de la neutralité la
neutralité c'est une neutralité surtout
militaire la suisse n'est pas partie
prenante au conflit armé
merci beaucoup gabriel galice et bien
d'avoir vécu avec nous en cette arrivée
de joe biden il ya quelques minutes
maintenant à l'aéroport international de
genève
joe biden qui vient de monter dans son
véhicule probablement pour rejoindre
l'hôtel l'hôtel intercontinental situé à
quelques kilomètres de notre position
pierre merci beaucoup olivet de kerran
flec pour tout ca précision merci de
nous avoir fait vivre en direct cette
arrivée du président américain vous le
disiez à l'aéroport international 2
m joe biden qui va rencontrer on le sait
bien dès demain vladimir poutine pour
pour un sommet merci à vous donc olivier
qui en fait l merci également à votre
invité merci également à jordy de mourir
derrière la caméra on vous retrouvera
bien entendu tout au long de cette
soirée puis et bien entendu demain pour
une large page consacrée à cette
rencontre entre eux à joe biden et
vladimir poutine